hello my name is vadim
and i would like to demonstrate uh how
to visualize our complicated data easily
i'm glad to show you how we're buying
for the platform firstly we need to go
to data integration and modeling zone
when we choose many volt utilities
section
now we are on the page
where we can process
our data set
with one of
manifold learning approaches which we
talked about earlier
such as either map
lle spectral umap diffusion maps and
other here we can choose
the type of
data set
it can be
object futures table or distance matrix
for graph
which will be used as pre-computing
graph for our manifold method let's get
object features table for mice
expression dataset and upload it into
platform
if you already know about
classes of our samples
when we can upload table with this
information tool
or if you don't know about it
we can skip this step
with this button
[Music]
in this data set
each row it is expression values of
70
proteins
the classes should be written
in the following form
first column
ideas of samples second column
classes
okay now we are ready to choose the
approach
which we would like to use
let's try um
this page shows us a small
description
of method
and it parameters
advanced users can change all of these
parameters
each parameter has a description
which you can get by hovering the mouse
over i icon near
parameter name
newbies in many folders can save default
parameters
and move to the next step
we press save button
i am filling the
name of
our pipeline
let's run it
we need to wait
for a little time
for pipeline to finish ready
then click download pipeline output
files
and choose
a png picture of our data manifold
embedding visualization
or you can choose
this txt file with the points
coordinates let's check a visualization
grid
new map approach works
we can see dividing of samples into two
clusters
control samples
and threesome samples